you
this is Dominic Dominic works at a
5-star restaurant called the pixel
palace they're some of videogames most
popular characters come in to have a
drink sometimes they share stories and
even secrets for as we all know what the
bartender hears is confidential isn't it
so on set there tending bar when in
walks a very nice bloke Donkey Kong now
donkey called me not be the brightest
banana on the tree but he's a real nice
guy so he sits down I make him a banana
daiquiri and I say oi DK what's been
going on he says big trouble at home I
go really well to town
he says Lee and Pauline have big fight I
go Oh Pauline them the woman that you
used to kidnap and keep at the top of
the Legos or whatever those were I don't
know you two got married and they said
well it start off as forth company but
then we get to like each other really
like each other
sex we had sex I said thank you I know
what you're talking about and also what
about Mario I thought he was always
trying to rescue her I said no he for
for other person Oh princess bitch I
think I said I think it's P Jesus no
it's bitch lord knows I'm not gonna
argue with a 10-ton gorilla so I said
okay princess bitch so I said well
what's the trouble with Pauline I mean
what's been going on I know things have
been pretty quiet with it I haven't seen
it on a video games or anything they
says well she stay at home more now
I said oh you mean did he call did he
call she's she's looking after did he
call and they said yes at times did he
come come with me on adventure
go-karting role but for the most part
Olli look after him so well okay that
sounds nice what's wrong with that and
they says Pauline and MIT did he call
not mine
I said oh you mean you mean you're not
the father he says no no Utz that's
terrible - do you know who the father is
did she tell you he looks down really
angry and he says Koko from Cocoa
Krispies I mean I guess it makes sense I
mean they both have bad and the t-shirt
and everything but I said I didn't even
know Polly Nana and a thing for monkeys
he says at first she did it
also okay I mean law knows how to know
how a 10-ton gorilla a medium-sized
woman
can even manage to okay I'm not going up
what am I Pauline has a thing for
monkeys and she cheated on Donkey Kong
with another monkey I don't know
so asked well what happened after that
they said she leave me and take Diddy
with her good call don't want her anyway
and I thought well this is rather sad he
doesn't have a family anymore but I
though wait a minute don't you have
another son looks down they says yes
Junior on the semen of course in a
Donkey Kong jr. he's in a few games so I
asked him I said well if family means so
much to you why don't you stop a
relationship with him again nice is he
playing for other team as a Playstation
he said homosexual as an arrow okay he
told me that he likes to put banana in
coconut and calm not approve and I'll
send well you know times are changing
mr. Kong you know there's a lot of
animal sexuals out there and prejudice
is a sign of very little intelligence
and you're not an unintelligent person
are you mr. Cole
you start eating his own feces and I
just wanted that question go and they
said Junior and a bomba notion I want
manly gorilla he wants Twilight I said
well it's a shame mr. Cole I mean you
seem like a real nice guy it's a shame
something like this should get in the
way he says Oh Kong don't want to talk
to you anymore
Kong leave now paid his champion headed
on out but on his way out speak of the
devil he actually comes across junior in
the bar he sitting there he's having a
drink with somebody and wouldn't you
know it he's having a drink with Linc
and if he knew half of what I knew about
Linc I would tell him in an instant
don't go with this guy's gonna break
your heart and do God knows what else do
you but it looked like jr. was crying as
I try to listen in I heard that link was
actually breaking up with him bit
surprised and as they were talking jr.
was saying why why are you breaking up
with me I thought we had something
something special and like says look we
had our fun I always want to won't be
like with a monkey but time to call it
off and jr. kept insisting please can't
we work it out can we do something about
this and Link said to him why would I
want to be associated with a damn dirty
ape
but they'll do they know that Donkey
Kong was standing there listening the
whole entire time he taps make on the
shoulder and he says that my son thinks
smiles with his cocky smile I says I'm
so very sorry for you
Donkey Kong grabs links head and smashes
it into the table ethan rips the hair
out of his head like you're peeling a
banana either smashed his body against
the wall maybe a couple dozen times and
they threw him out the window
and of course juniors just standing that
dumbfound he doesn't know what to say
but he does manage to look up at his
father and he says thanks dad Donkey
Kong looks down and he says you still
bye son you walked out the door and they
never look back now some say that he
went straight home and he called his son
they talked for hours after that but I
know he went the back alley and kept
beating the shit out of link I mean
either way it was a great affection of
love and it was very very touching even
if it is unbelievably violent a gory
I mean links remains afterwards well
yeah I'll surprise to you alive but what
can I say a monkey's love for his son is
just an unbreakable bond and that night
will certainly grow for that you see a
lot of strange things as a mall tender
seal all strange things at the pixel
palace so I'll seal
as a bartender at the pixel baths and
that ain't no lie sweater
you